all right kirsten spring is here and  that means many of us are looking to  clear out our our clutters and with some  spring cleaning right but did you know  sprucing up your finances is as  important as cleaning your home so  listen to this a recent survey says 14  percent of people want to beef up their  savings and another 20 percent of people  said paying down debt is their main  financial goal this year but sometimes  that's easier said than done right cbs  news business analyst jill schislinger  said has some tips for us  look at where you're spending and  usually people can find a little bit of  of fudge factor there some money that  they can allocate towards debt pay down  next you want to actually create a list  and say okay what is my highest interest  debt right now  all right she recommends you prioritize  so you're not overwhelmed and keep on  top of your credit score  well